hi everybody walk with string Coco clap
you son-of-a-bitch clap that's how I
treat our intern Riley I yelled at him
because he wasn't clapping uh hello
everyone welcome its maximum sauce
Monday I got my soy sauce shirt on from
Target this is actually just what I was
wearing it's not a funny stream Coco's
shirt welcome we got uh we got this
little thing it's the old Nintendo
switcheroo and we're gonna play some
Legend of Zelda today breath of the wild
very excited this thing is cool I got to
say we've been playing with it audios a
little out of sync dope that's okay I'll
just talk slower and this is dope it's
interesting like look at this thing like
these are great and they're tiny
that pretty cool so yeah it's different
whatever that's whatever is called it
was great and I got to the third stage
it's awesome like science it's great
maybe what we might place that and I
play some snipper Clippers a little bit
later which is very exciting
what's going on y'all hate chat hey chat
hey Louie what's up there's cockroaches
in my mic I hope that's not true it's
probably crickets if my life is anything
I'm gonna have to repeat all that
toku 98 cents by the way for those of
you having trouble getting the switch on
Amazon Prime just had them restocked so
it's worth checking out
but anyway I was saying we got the
switch it's fantastic and here's the
cool thing you press a little button on
the back and these babies pop out and
they just become their own little there
are little controllers which is great
and they even have the buttons up top
those two little buttons up top so you
can still play like this and even me a
person with big hands small for my size
I don't want to hear about it uh it's
still really fun to play so all that
being said twice let's play some Zelda
shall we new game please and I haven't
even played this at all so I'm very
excited
snip Eclipse and we might play some what
is it called
snippet clipper yeah that's your new
name is now I have to say something this
might be in a popular opinion I've never
actually been a fan of Legend of Zelda
I've never been a fan I played ocarina
of time I played the [ __ ] out of that
game it was awesome beat it was so fun
haven't picked up his eldest sense I had
before really saw this whole game over
my boyfriend shoulder for like I suck
Thank You Louie love you too yes cringe
cringe cringe snip Rick Lippert I'm a
popular because I'm a fan of Zelda it's
not that I'm not a fan it's just there's
so much backstory there I just haven't
played a lot of me now it doesn't mean
I'm not a fan but you know what breath
of the wild might make I can find it all
weekend best the wild which is important
top anytime you can put your own name
into something I'm a big fan Beth is the
best at that thank you
you mean link not zelda tuck dragons
right yeah link dude again it's not that
I'm not a fan of Zelda I just haven't
played I don't have a lot of experience
with Zelda it's like saying I mean I'm
also you know not a fan of kissing women
because I it's not that I'm not a fan of
kissing women I just haven't done a lot
of it I don't bad analogy it's like
getting punched in the stomach it's not
that I'm not a fan of getting punched in
the stomach it's that I just haven't bad
example
all I'm saying is I just haven't played
a lot of back it up
links in a tub is basically like Master
P's house you don't look like a fan of
kissing women all right I'd like to set
myself up for that one who a lot of a
mood a lot of emotes here Wow a lot of
heads in the chat Monster Hunter never
played it whoo here we go all right see
I'm looking there's a lot of
constellations here this you know what
this looks like
I've never been to we spa but I feel
like this is very we spa there's just
gonna be a woman that's gonna come out
and hit link on the back a bunch of
times and Lincoln's looking pretty good
how old am I I'm an elf right you have
just been asleep 400 years
oh I just got me it's got crazy deja vu
by the way I just gotten crazy DJ vu you
saying
eventually 400 years but then I think
you stabbed me I've been having some
weird dreams lately guys we play a lot
of Resident Evil seven and then I go to
sleep immediately afterwards this is
what happens at the we spa right sign it
please sign in this is like this is like
Equinox
you know what don't tell me
yeah it's the note if the samsung note
12 is what it is
stabby don't tell him to stab me movin
dolls what the hell dude did I just get
a new Nintendo switch in the game you
just got a pokedex this is I just got a
pro kit you just got a switch exactly
yeah switch off switch ON switch I don't
know where cotton is he's probably in
his own giant weird looking we spot toe
up in his office he has to soak a lot of
people don't know this he has to soak
like Darth Vader for 23 hours out of
every 24 hours because his skin is so
delicate and fragile and he was actually
thrown into a volcano by his mentor him
and Anna can share a lot of well-worn
trousers they can't give me new trousers
damn all right
you know what no I'm not gonna equip
trousers equip travel you know what in
real life I have to wear pants and in
the in a game this is how I escaped I
refuse to wear pants nope not doing it
sorry I have shapely legs and yeah I
want to show them up what's the point
ooh hey look I can move this giant box
that will come in handy never you know
let me live out my fantasy of not
wearing pants old shirt so far I get an
old shirt and old pants you know what
done it's like vintage hi I'm gonna put
the shirt on because I think it's
creepier to wear a shirt and no pants
than it is to just be in your underwear
I also like this could just be shorts
they're pretty tight they're pretty
form-fitting baths look at this let's
look down a little bit can I get down
these are lasered yeah
ah now what is a here's my first problem
at this game when I get into get a good
look at my butt it won't I disappear I
can't get up in there all the nooks and
crannies that I want to see switch so
far two stars out of five tight
how are we supposed to abduct Conan we
don't notice don't abduct Conan guys cuz
then I wouldn't have a job and your boys
been eatin his Wheaties Jesus this is my
hey I'm walking here
hey alright sorry there's no bumbum
camera you feel me serving perv proof
you know what we'll see about that
this pervs got a lot more tricks up his
sleeves they don't you worry about me
being pervert I like this voice it
sounds like the ghost of Christmas past
in the Muppet Christmas Carol that's a
very specific reference and by the way a
correct link is never nude yeah you're
right hey Matt David Cross wouldn't it
be great if link was played by David
Cross and movie Andy must stay naked
baby will we make a close gamer about
breath of the wild I don't know maybe if
this goes well who knows sky's the limit
guys but I'll tell you right now the
fact I can't look at my own butt big
strike against a close game that's one
of my favorite things to do what if I
survive 30 minutes Espie reom please
it's Elda how hard could it be that's it
you know what that showed off my package
pretty well
[Music]
okay here's what I know about and sell
me let's go over let's go over the back
story shall we
Hyrule is the is the Kingdom which is an
interesting name because you if you want
a rule Hyrule you sound dumb you know
what I'm saying like if you're a bad guy
you're like I want to rule Hyrule that
you you yeah it's kind of self-defeating
for any kind of big speech you know
there's water I don't have barefoot you
know what I don't have her any shoes
this is cool
it was glutes and zelda is a girl is a
female elf I know we're in a genderless
post-gender society but I think she's
female or identifies as a binary female
that's Mount Doom where Frodo has to
take the ring right that's part of this
maybe this part was originally this is
where Simba was yep before he gets
killed right or Simba's dad liked the
valley I've also never seen The Lion
King
that's actually a true thing I've never
seen The Lion King I know it sounds
crazy but it's true I've never seen the
Lion King guys today's just gonna be
full of hate the chat's is gonna be full
of hate your boys know hey there's a
mysterious stranger in all dark clothing
let's run after him shall we great a
tree branch is my weapon you know what I
wasn't kidding about the we spot thing
this is exactly what happened to the me
spot well I do have to say I love these
graphics the shell the shell city the
shading is awesome so [ __ ] yeah my tree
branch is badly damaged all I did was
hit one mushroom this thing sucks
ooh okay
shrooms bro you gonna get high whoa hey
look at this I can climb up stuff yeah
whoops Dan your boys got some can I call
up anything in this game bet you've
played this game you can climb up you
just get ties try a tree nope can't
climb up a tree I'm hitting the wrong
button and I mean the right button here
we go oh yeah look at that oh I see okay
all right great
[Music]
alejandro thank you for saying I'm not
funny I appreciate that it's always good
to be humbled by people in the chat what
else you guys got today I can climb
everything thank you two guys vide holic
Elish I'll have shrooms plays college
like my drug of choice in college was
cheese and depression what's that
what oh yeah its target guys it's a fine
store it's a fine store many nice
graphic to use plenty graphic tees there
that's right hey nerve yeah I read
comments Tyra boy that I do we want
daddy Conan Alejandro you know a great
way to get Conan here is to insult me
that's a great idea
Colin hey guy a guy who's in charge of
the chat go screw yourself hey do me a
favor might want to rethink that
strategy friend I never tried shrooms
I'm not a big drug guy I prefer to read
quietly by myself mascot I did drink a
lot of mezcal in Mexico we got some fire
over here oh here's this dude now this
dude looks wise
well met but you know what I appreciate
that that's very nice of me oh no wait a
second don't put yourself down pal
are you got chili you know I am kind of
chilly mmm they're asking why I don't
have pants on
exactly I like to have my junk be free
and Hyrule I'm here for laptop girl here
it goes kablooey yep that's some
coincidence I shall tell you there's the
great plateau according to legend is the
birthplace of the entire kingdom of
Hyrule oh my god it's a lot you are very
tall
adil t' 2:13 this game does look amazing
this is a very cool game I have to say
by the way switch controller great yeah
light it's easy temple there long ago is
the site of many secret ceremonies this
is a clan of the kingdom 100 years ago
set the ban in a state of decay all
right drink whiskey and talk to
strangers you feel me Kari Nora they
never really do yeah they don't -
voiceover okay well that guy's pretty
dope
hey I got a torch oh sorry
haha I guess I'm a jerk sorry old man
uh I don't think I'm gonna do either one
of these I think I'm gonna use it to
light my way well then I like secrets
too so who you may have it
I'm Kim lasers whip it it was face your
opponents and lock your sights on them I
sense it too a tutorial coming on all
right let's go wood cutters axe this is
great throw this weapon Oh No
I destroyed my tree branch you guys do
you think I'm gonna step on anything
like prickers or anything bad monster
there's one oh is that a monster already
[Music]
know what is that blobby thing blob
monster
Jesus why is everything already chasing
me ah maybe the blob can't come upstairs
no man he's still coming after me oh
there's another monster up here later
bro right into the braid hand-holding I
think these guys can't get me up here
wherever I am on the ground wait how do
I switch weapons here ah the blob thing
I should pull out that axe what do you
think about that idea
Coenen chasing employees yeah haha can't
get me on this side Kenya all right you
know what time to stop running where's
my accent yeah you know what hey oh now
who's running should I try to kill this
blob thing of my ass see you know stuff
look at it I'm really rolling towards it
wait what's my thing again how do I here
we go
what's attack B nope see the thing is
trigger puts it away which is annoying
what's what what's happening what am i
doing how do I swing my stupid axe I
don't want to throw it everyone's leave
the blob alone he's cute
I was mad that he's a bad guy how do how
do I you guys what am i doing did why
okay why I did that I thought yeah why
by the way is jump who ever Oh No why is
this oh there we go okay alright here we
go
where's the blob at blob man disappeared
let's go kill this stupid thing the blob
just sunk into the ground
yeah boy Oh Oh what now [ __ ] oh yeah
extra sauce I'll take that Club thank
you
we just dropped his club oh wait
anything else over here we've got I got
a bubble Blin horn for coupling horn
separate horn of Avoca Blin how jealous
are you that I have a book of Lin horn
you have nothing I had so many noise
thank you missing blob wanted to be
friends you in spite of the threat of
violence no no is that true I don't love
a parade no blob tried it you mm-hmm all
right
well now that I know how to attack
nothing can stop me nothing you hear me
game don't even try to send anything to
stop me huh you know what I will I do
like this a lot I hate being able going
up a hill and then not being able to
actually get up there super annoying
throw myself into Conan's office window
what does that would that be like
refrence offense training myself instead
of defense training I throw myself into
a window instead of out of it word joke
hello elegant projects hello from
Burbank looks like a cel-shaded shadow
of mordor I think there's a little
bigger difference than just that miss P
[ __ ] I'm over here oh yeah that sucks
for you
you know what dog that's just
embarrassing man later through the
uprights well I'm gonna take your club
so now what you're coming back up here
you stay down there I guess they're
gonna here finish you off I hate to
leave a boku Blinn unsatisfied you know
oh
it's Britney [ __ ] guys so far this game
is pretty great there's a lot less
[ __ ] than I was expecting I was
expecting a lot of BS and I'm getting a
lot of awesome s a lot of a s oops
priceless artifacts do I need to take
everything who's there something I could
throw at this that lets reddit that
statue oh hey hey Lunas from Finland
good to see you
oops
well that's fun
woman let's pray we pray everyday
all right Deb but what's the little
oscillating oh that's how much noise I'm
making guy yeah
still waiting for NES mini Theodore it's
worth the wait it's awesome
I can cut trees as well Oh interesting
I don't want to I don't want to dull my
blade on anything but the skulls of my
enemies thank you can I please taste the
cartridge on Zelda I heard it tastes
disgusting
there's no cartridge we downloaded it so
not sure exactly what better TV correct
this is not clueless gamer
we're just clueless this is just a
stream
it was missed coming up from the ground
oh wait I'm supposed to be following
this thing press my face on Conan's
office wind up guys
Conan's office is not on the ground
floor yeah okay very high you don't know
what you're asking
hashtag it Conan Tichy quick hashtag
etiquette you want to make it all one
word cuz you just used hashtag get go to
the blinking dot blinking dot that's
where I was I'm dumb I show this is just
stream I don't know spike mitts
it depends now if you think the entire
construct of our reality is just a bunch
of basically two-dimensional harddrive
stacked on each other to simulate a 3d
reality we're all just playing a game
that Elon Musk 10,000 years in the
future actually just is created for
people to play on whatever passes for an
iPhone or it could also just be a string
hashtag get I love you guys
Spyder Blake Conan's office window you
know what Spyder bling is is spitting up
on my food before I eat it like a spider
that's nothing to do with climbing whoo
Christopher Hart hmm I guess I am
passive-aggressive if that's what you
think of me I guess I am I don't know
you tell me what I am I'm not sure I
mean I don't think I'm
passive-aggressive but you know maybe
that's just could just be you projecting
send nudes where do you want me to send
nudes to Ivan
I have a lot of great nudes of Ryan
Reynolds I'm what I would love to send
them to somebody actually was really
cool when we were in New York I was
standing by the coffee machine in the
greenroom waiting for they're gonna go
get their vocal things you know what
your mother tell you it's not nice to
light things on fire look what I got
[Music]
you know what how come you can just pick
pick up flaming that's a tough skin
there bro he's like they're eggs or
something it was actually very cool when
we were in York I was standing by the
coffee machine I didn't realize that I
was standing in front of it and in the
greenroom waiting for I can't remember I
was doing something and she was like oh
excuse me it was Ryan Reynolds that's
like oh hey and I actually got to talk
to him for like a good like 15 20
minutes was awesome
20 minutes is too much it was probably
like 30 seconds but time slows when
you're staring into Ryan Reynolds dreamy
eyes but it was cool we talked a little
bit about his life and Deadpool too and
I I saw the trailer for Deadpool 2 but I
haven't seen Logan yet but I really want
to and I was actually straight he was
incredibly cool I mean exactly like you
would think which is great and I told
him some weird story about catching my
back hair in his zipper on wearing a
skin-tight suit when I played a Taco
Bell on tour so that's how I talk to
famous people you know typical stuff you
want to talk to Ryan Reynolds about did
I mention I a horribly embarrass myself
in every situation hi my name is Aaron
I what is the deal with tasting I'm not
sure what your fetish is about tasting
cartridges I like it and I respect it I
don't share it we only have downloaded
games read by nature I really want to
see you Logan
I love I know it's different but I love
the old man Logan yeah I love the old
man Logan comic but and I love Hugh
Jackman I think you do even though as we
all know way too tall play Wolverine
obviously Jackie Earle Haley is probably
a bet would probably be a more
appropriate Wolverine because he's
insane and super gruff and psychotic and
shortly and like ripped but
default gecko if your hair is that
perfectly white I'd be dying out you
know the thing is about white hair is it
doesn't actually Hey look Hyrule is
getting boners guys we hit the boner but
how rules getting a bunch of boners it's
awesome but but love hugh jackman in
that role it's great like the earth come
on now you're that ginger now you're
just reaching low goes great don't bring
your kids uh I won't I mean the kids
I've stolen from a local park no I won't
bring them anyway they don't leave that
I don't let them leave the house that
happened oh I see the empty screen
Nintendo added a bittering agent to the
cartridges so kids won't eat them but
now every person is social is licking
them as a challenge got it thank you for
explaining that instead of just telling
me to lick a cartridge well I don't know
we don't have any cartridges here no
does the switch even take cartridges
yeah they're little like they look like
like SD cards that used to put in like
to a phone got it that's why they added
a bittering agent what if kids you know
sour patch kids are a really popular
candy and they're super bitter also
warheads very popular yeah maybe it's
just making them salivate and wanting
them to
imagine if you actually were asleep how
much I cook you'd have it just be like
to just giant fists of just I cook you
know am I making you about to throw up
alright I gotta try harder
oh this guy looks bad you know the thing
is maybe he's a good guy I think that
there's too much prejudice in games you
know spoiler alert No well what is the
bad lady what is the bad lady play by
the rock cuz that would be awesome
she's not right but I want her to be
apparently earned is another difference
means sour bitter I'm sorry is there a
difference
well yes but like I feel like in the
vendée
a lemon sour or bitter C I would say
bitter I say bitter is like like like
bitters got it hey what is a color red
lik like right blink dies in the end
John we all die in the end so there you
go yeah oh yeah I have that bug ever
ready no I'm thinking of
there's nothing what I'm thinking of I
think it is yeah and they made it into a
movie
this must be dope great just gonna jump
off here real quick stupid okay earwax
is like a bitter white wax smells like
fried chicken I don't about you guys
earwax is bitter all right chocolate
cake is bitter Aaron it's not sugar is
bitter what are you guys talking about
oh there's about to be a third john dies
at the end
look i freed the first one I heard it
was great I have it there's heaven by
David Wong I believe I'm currently
finishing Eileen but you read it's baby
so good so weird also I read all the
profit which is
great great graphic novel very very dead
link ah I got it check her out
Kayla's better every time but I love
kale every time linked eyes were just
gonna call it a 404 it's a dead link
[Music]
they murder on the feet
I don't wanna see don't understand that
if she meets our better
like what like like that one weeks ago
[Laughter]
guys you're not watching episode of
chef's table this is actually stream
code
oh my god the expansive by palate it's
only only put to shame by the expanse of
my nomen for booze no me what bitter has
no tang what does that mean okay but I
drink coffee and I like the taste you
guys are not doing a great job
explaining this I do have the sriracha
shirt yes I have all shirts basically
hashtag all shirts
nothing like a really long climb
uneventful climb down day three of link
climbing down oh sorry could be a flavor
all better just tastes bad bitter is
more of a reaction where sours more of a
flavor I don't know man you know what I
think you guys dark chocolate is great I
think if I come across you those
cartridges I'm probably gonna eat them
because it probably probably tastes
great you know I don't understand why
you need to make a cartridge taste
bitter it already tastes like plastic
that is a flavor no one wants to eat is
the flavor of plastic or burnt burnt
plastic or burnt hair
why bitter there's stuff that's bitter
that's delicious man come on Nintendo a
bitter old grandpa yeah you know what
and I tasted Grandpa and it was gross
hey it's the old guy on a homemade paper
kite these boners have erupted across
the land did you do this
it's almost as though a long-dormant
power you know what I like you know I'd
love to see in a in a game just people
who have ever read a book or played a
game before yeah you know like oh
alright what's up with these towers I
don't know it's so crazy like guys
there's clearly something going on
there's clearly everyone saw that bad
guy up here or the guy who he's supposed
to be bad it's like read a book
anyone in a movie or a game like that's
why I appreciate like the movie cabin in
the woods oh yeah because that was a
great horror movie where people knew
that they were in a horror movie and it
was awesome and it was great and I loved
that it was smart sandy was scream
scream was another very one one of the
first actually to kind of do that Wes
Craven going back to his roots pretty
great I'm not reading any of this I'm
just you know we all know what this is
we all know what this is the moment is
happening I'll know what this is man
YouTube chat you guys are a bunch of
dicks I'm gonna say it right now you
guys just why are you even watching this
yes go back to study hall or whatever
you're doing like don't even want like
why do you watch something that you hate
I just don't understand just you're
wasting your life do you understand this
is time you'll never have back and you
hate me fine but then don't watch like
what's the big deal you're not gonna
make me feel worse than I already feel
about myself so you know I just don't
get it but hey man it's your life
exactly oh I'm in work well Flavio go
back to work
or go watch something else go watch like
the best bane quotes from Dark Knight
Rises or something leave me alone all
right here we go we're having fun by the
way twitch chats killing it today we're
still figuring out the difference
between sour and bitter over there this
is great it's an app the twitch chats in
touch with scotch on YouTube just like
yeah you suck it's like okay great I get
it what else you got what else you got
or if you're gonna you guys are gonna
like crap on me at least make it
interesting you know what I'm saying
yeah and these put a little thought into
it yeah yeah don't just come with some
lame-ass insults they no one cares about
you and cares about that you have no
effect on my life at all let's go over
to this big weird thing over here twitch
chat is better in YouTube Jenna's very
sour actually I feel like YouTube chats
probably more bitter people I look like
I'm 7000 multi dirt bro
got it do do better do better
whoo hot foot if Rock cook it with
monster parts and draw it at speed boots
effect
dude I can cook up monsters in this game
I love this
we got we got a water - shine here Oman
[Music]
well there'd be a VR clueless gamer your
lips to God's ears it's all hope so well
we did do it wasn't a gamer we did do a
really cool Bethel put a link to it in
the chat we went to the YouTube space
and did a bunch of really cool VR games
that was awesome that was really really
fun he actually didn't he actually
didn't want to take the VR goggles off
yeah and it was like they're really
perfecting the way of like other people
to conceive er instead of it just being
inside someone's mind yeah
the mixed reality thing is extremely
cool and thank you for it to the YouTube
people not the people in the chat
currently but the people who made
YouTube thank you to the people at
YouTube space New York for helping us
out with that it was really fun we had a
really good time we hope to do that
someday
YouTube chat Erin Blair is a
reincarnated Benjamin Button I think he
just called me Brad Pitt is that
supposed to be God you guys just are
terrible at cut downs look at this this
is very Stargate II I was like you know
what I do like I like that the
combination of like a fantasy element
and like I'm futuristic yeah
it's very cool oh that's cool oh you
mean the mag nice finishes trial all
right oh so we got a puzzle here this is
a puzzle right okay well not really it's
cool-looking just look at the reflection
on the gap that's so cool all right what
do we got here got some constellations
this reminds me of an escape room I did
once have uridine escape room no dude
you gotta do it so fun what's this over
here go check it out I'm gonna go put
mine I'm gonna go for my personal device
in here first name Beth displayed this I
have not you want Jim lead to a demo and
VR Wow there's ski that's cool
whoa dope man I maybe think about it a
super futuristic technology the idea is
to kind of make it more natural-looking
yeah like you would want it to be all
ruins and stones and stuff you know like
instead of all steel and chrome ah pick
man 44 I will tell Ken you said hi
escape rooms are the bomb I agree my
device is tiny see Titan Heroes I know
you didn't mean that as a cut down but
Titan hero that's a great cut down your
device is tiny I thought that was really
yeah maybe a Menelik magnet metallic
objects using mag magnetism oh my god
I've had so much coffee today all right
here we go so that's an ability I have
you can lift up those like things you
were walking on okay oh I see this to
pick them up
whoops sweet whoops just wanted to make
sure I could still throw stuff all right
so what do I do now there we go so now
no oh god what happened yeah there we go
dope oh this is awesome
look at this giant piece of toast I got
what am i doing with the toast oh wait I
just want to move it I think cool
awesome man
ooh Pizza raid on the old YouTube coming
we got a lot more follow like I guess
now it's a raid
enjoy a raid love it it's actually the
best conversation we've had so far with
YouTube chat today just people writing
pizza did send us a pizza
no kidding I mean you know it's a bummer
Mike Ilitch died he was the the guy who
made Little Caesars Pizza big Detroit
guy pretty dope owned the Red Wings
owned part of the Tigers killer I love
crazy bread I know very sad
well you know what I want to do is I
want to take this out of here anything
holy oops
now if there's one dammit son-of-a-bitch
pull the [ __ ] sting out hate you
[Music]
oh crap yeah this thing sucks Wow damn
it
can I put it on my on top of that dude
your facee dumb thing hey anything for
that ain't she's free I gotta say if I
was a hoarder I would love videogames
because in videogames I oh man just got
toasted ha ha well played who said that
PC guy 89 best best comment so far today
[Music]
have to move this thing again or what
wait so where did you play this back did
you play it all I was sitting next to
reading the New York I love it
everyone I really recommend the Russia
David Remnick oh I love David Remnick
it's always good when REM Nix involved
that make sense
I mean that meat which issues twitches
all right
oh whoops rise I say rise rotate this
rise
I should be a professional toast mover
guys instead of thing my term in a
minute
people are saying that refresh things to
work everything refreshing oh wait a
second someone's trying to start a
burrito raid on YouTube YouTube is
insane man you guys are crazy
hey it's freaking how's that look like
looks kind of like Star Wars and looks
like a mummified Yoda yeah it's like
evil Yoda
[Music]
great great cheekbones good good
structure
[Music]
guys I think we're about to get a spirit
orb Oh woo hey hey whoa whoa whoa whoa
[Music]
who said we were gonna beat the third
first 30 minutes of this are you flying
I do you know something that's because
you kind of said that a foreboding way
you're like I think we've done fairy
no I thought I think it took longer that
bad oh my god they're still doing raids
on YouTube watching YouTube is like when
you slow down on the side of highways
just a terrible accident that's what
every time I look at the YouTube chat
that's what I see is the game very
difficult I've been seeing a lot of ESPE
reom I've been seeing a lot of Dark
Souls like Zelda Dark Souls comparisons
I think if you belong against did you go
on it gets much harder
one gets older oh my god alright God we
know the shrine and the awakening just
gave me to the part where I kill things
with an axe anytime they show me find
any pants though I'm digging it it's not
dark souls analysis windsock yeah it's a
disappearing technology come on guys
please just show me something new you
know
I'll get a paraglider that's fun I just
want to see some new kind of
storytelling you know you don't actually
send us a pizza please no don't say that
send us a pizza
no why are you saying no to beaches well
make the interns eat it right Riley
he'll eat it alright don't send us
anything how about that don't send us
food unless you're pop chips
unless your pops thanks for the giant
bag of pop chips that was dope
you don't say this Pizza I can't eat
carbs anyway yeah Beth Beth only Bethel
he eats like a grain of rice a day oh
I'm so full a very large bag she lives
off T and a dust motes that's what
you're like you're like you're like
Fievel you're like Fievel follow this
West great cry every time I see that
read a freaking book skips all dialogue
I just want to see a new kind of
storytelling you know man I've read a
lot of books all right I know how
stories are told played a lot of games
is it too much to ask for something new
you know
a kata Meyer Demasi only comes by once
every decade all right what's a
generation I understand I mean look this
is not the game wow this is a very tall
should we go down here did you do did
you get the parachute oh I did I didn't
wasn't paying attention on how to use it
let's go back
there's the magnets we got magnets
that's how you can wait to let your
horses
we got whistling we got our thing here
let's go to the okay don't want to do
that oh you know we should do is save
let's save shall we and it's saved in a
bit see you please I kind of would like
this game you probably would juggle
Germania well never know he's getting
his hair cut sorry
key items well we got the spirit orb
which is living inside us which by the
way I'm a little uncomfortable about
it's just weird like what if I'm out of
medication you know what I'm saying like
you can't mix spirit orbs and random
medications you don't know maybe I'm
gonna like lipitor or something or I'm
on a blood thinner and they give me a
spirit orb and it makes my blood thinner
and then I die I bleed out from the
inside good you know shrine guy evil
Yoda think about that okay next time you
put a spirit orb in somebody's chest
Jesus Christ all right where we going
here invent your log don't care memories
have none because I've been asleep for a
hundred years and have two giant soft
balls I cook over my face all right here
we go
well I don't know how to do if I just
jump off is it gonna do it we just saved
is the paraglider gonna happen
automatically we're trying it I'm just
gonna jump off nope nope no paraglider
didn't work very did didn't even like
tell us it was over there like no it
just gave us up the middle finger just a
giant middle finger came up oh wait that
dang nope not that thing you don't have
it clap I'd like to hear like deaf count
to trust us dangled bot they said that
we didn't get it we didn't get it oh did
I know Oh double press x-cubed says
cubis I'm gonna try what you said Kubis
by the way you are speaking for the
entire YouTube chat and if this is
[ __ ] alright Kubis here we go q miss
why don't I listen to the YouTube chat
oh all you guys care about is pizza
parties and things yeah you guys care
about bitter pizza and oh you're dying
screaming at each other about burritos
alright Oh eat something alright what do
I eat here can I know on this branch I
don't have any food I don't think oh
wait that Apple's food oh I got a ton of
food you know what okay sorry I just
wanted to do that I feel so much better
these are gonna stop me up I'm sad it's
a lot of shrimps is that gonna I don't
love YouTube more than more than you
guys it's just they're fun to screw it
because they're crazy
okay got it
oh-ho-ho dark Santa evil Santa what if
that guy turns out to be Santa they'll
be pretty great finish the shrines thank
you
you're welcome so leader plainness does
exist I bet there's a bunch of bad guys
we're gonna come out soon oh I hear now
we can now we can find out how many
licks it takes to get to the center of a
Tootsie Roll pop you know what go Glee
Oh Helios that's a good question is
there a Chuck Norris video game I don't
know oh oh oh something's after me oh
something's after me well I don't want
to be prejudiced but yes it's a monster
you know I like it I'd like to get to
know a creature before I call it a
monster like my ex-girlfriend snap up
top all Acoustics on point I agree with
that
ooh what are these little things hey
corn you say okay
I'm running Masson what I think of death
stranding Ivan well it's not out yet is
it but goddamn does it look cool
although I got to kill this thing real
quick oh yeah oh man I love that move
it's real satisfying killing these
suckers
[Music]
what so I like to hit him right in the
butt guys I like to hit it in the butt
that's what I'm saying oh I'm knocked
his tooth out goddamn damn link has got
an arm on him uh sure she was a nice
woman the ex she's actually that's you
she's actually writing I'm sure she was
a nice woman um well I'm here
Slayer Darth we have everything the hell
am i hearing today I don't know what
what it bands a bunny play overwatch
Sebastien Garcia maybe we will way we'll
play overwatch with us some you guys
next week
we did play with Peter Dinklage and Lena
Headey from Game of Thrones it was super
awesome I might hit this and go to I
supposed to be going
hey you play this before where do I go
any idea yeah we're the shrines huh
I just got to wander around there should
be a glowy thing right later dangle
cookies banana what do you guys think
where are the shrines at the high tower
you say okay to the high tower I shall
go the old man said so sure brother
dialog yeah that's true you're right I'm
a doofus I should have read the dialog
no wait you sing these blob things are
my friend Kelly can I get blob one thing
I know are blobs they don't like to be
hugged climb the boner climb it I shall
I shall ascend to the tip of the tower
put your mind out of the gutter the tip
top you didn't let me finish please stop
talking about food Oh God
Jodi oh good I'm so sorry good luck with
your surgery Ian Quinn ask Conan when it
was like acting with Cher and mask now
see you guys are ripping on Conan better
than you're ripping on me that's a
pretty good cut down Eric Stoltz by the
way is amazing that movie it's a great
movie
now we're back one thing you know what I
will say is I do like Nintendo does here
we go this only takes six years Nintendo
does great at music and sound put your
choo-choo jelly on the tip oh you guys
don't ever change chat don't ever change
get that stam in a bag yet let's go I
didn't climb the tower yet I was on top
of it because I think it appeared below
[Music]
so I put this old man in retirement you
know what's crazy as I read a statistic
somewhere that was like the largest or
the fastest spread of STDs are on the
rise because of people in old folks
homes yeah isn't that great yeah I love
that oh well he's dying over there
that's true I think that's like a real
thing so guys if you're in a retirement
home wrap it up you know wrap it up beat
be safe be safe a bunch of casanova's
and castle ladies out there making it
happen
getting all sexy out there in the
retirement home I blame viagra a lot of
us do web feet with which which button
is that to rub the jelly all over my
pants
wait Jodie says I'm a British
firefighter and I fell about 14 feet
through a house roof this morning Laurie
is that true my god I'm glad you're okay
and thanks for watching this chat unless
of course you're like in a full-body
cast and somebody put it on and they're
torturing you with it like a Clockwork
Orange in which case I'm really sorry
that you're stuck in the YouTube chat
and you're on the twitch chat because
they're much nicer in the twitch chat
although you know what youtube you guys
are start to behave yourselves I
appreciate it or maybe just all the
pizza party people got to hungry and
left yeah
yeah you got to be safe out there I
agree Jordan
I bet link could do like a thousand
pull-ups he looks like he's got a large
back oh man did I go around the wrong
way it's gonna fall I don't care
do we need a staff rabbit uh I think it
would be great if we had rabbit sons -
don't you think I think he's at rabbi Oh
daddy yeah
oh sorry well I don't think we need
rabbis either I mean we have Robo rabbi
still the robot so and guess what he's
gonna last for thousands of years this
power source
he's got a tiny nuclear engine power
sources
how far is in the game all of them we've
only been playing for about an hour and
a half so not very far now wait how did
this guy get up here come on
yeah I forgot got it cool no I didn't
know about it Oh press that and then hit
that Oh
[Music]
Koecher programming you know it reading
is for wussies that's true yeah I know
habla espanol I'm sorry even though I
did speak a little espanol in Mexico
City Gandalf for Santa I don't know
enough I guess no no all right here we
go
yeah okay
whoa look at that over there all right
so I'm gonna hit this no I see I can put
all my pins in one place if I really
want to go there that's where I would go
you know yeah
all right let's edit our pins okay
there's a pin we don't care about that
shrine of resurrection we were there
before so we are now
oh we were there before no do we gonna
try resurrection maybe not I think that
oh I keep getting my A's and B's and all
mixed up in the shrines
oh I see what you mean okay so we want
to pin the shrines here so there's
probably what there's one here probably
I don't know right trying to
resurrection is where we started trying
around that's where we were resurrected
Oh got it
okay so I'm just supposed to look around
for these fricking shrines that looks
like one right over there na I guess now
how do I get rid how do I hit my pins Oh
God this is kind the other glowy hunts
their glowy hunts the glowy things
everyone who's saying the word glowy
the glowy things on the map
one on top of mountain and one in a sort
of group of room hey look it's 59
degrees Fahrenheit in Hyrule right now
oh cool look to the right of the other
tower oh I see okay there's one south
the temple of time I guess so let's
stick one year great oh look the right
of the other tower oh I see
oh the glowy things oh I got it okay
wait we did see a glowy thing remember
there's a glowy thing over here there's
a glowy thing right there boom and there
was one I saw there's one these the
glowy things are talking about
oh yeah the orange
[Music]
I'll expect you in a more vibrant glow
are these Cloe things I'm gonna put one
there just in case and put one up here
at guys we're feeling sassy alright
and there's wow that's looks like it
smells really bad over there all right
well I think we've got a lot of glowy
things to go see everyone saying no no
how do we do oh the thing the last two I
shouldn't have done these things are not
purple and green I should take out
this is only two yeah okay I got it I
got it purple and green I gotta take out
fine all right there we go
all right I think we're ready great only
got 15 minutes okay now hold of them oh
you know what here I can actually fast
travel wait a second oh my god this is
so complicated all right here we go do
this and then let's do this and then do
all right travel to this guy here there
we go whoo quantum leap oh boy
purple was good oh sorry leap of faith
we did that Beast wheat there's one more
Elvira says all right we'll find it
I think Aaron should handle the chat we
need an actual good player how brother
cab talk Beth and Blair the mom and dad
of terrible gameplay that is correct
it's true you are correct
stamp collector premium team Coco's new
PewDiePie we don't have nearly enough
followers for that kind of moniker but
tank yeah he should really put on those
pants why are the pants gonna help me in
some way
burning torch or goblin Club will help
me oh I see it's gonna get cold up there
oh I guess I should put on those pants
all right you know what I'm putting on
the pants but not because I like wearing
pants but because it's important for the
game okay hey quick uh I live by your
rules I guess oh Jesus
well I guess I'll just stay on this side
of things cause it's not that cold over
here link is gonna get trench foot if
you doesn't wear some shoes I got shoes
on all right pants will slow you down B
take more damage and some of us guys
you'd be surprised you'll find a light
best part of Mexico definitely meeting
people I mean we all the awesome people
we met were we're absolutely amazing
really nice really cool and they act
they really made our our whole trip
worth it can I just climb up here can I
just all right oh I always
[Music]
got a Boca boat boat chug them out
[Music]
oh that sucks and I'm dead
how did uh how do you dodge would be a
good thing to maybe figure out you know
how would the stupid eat that bacon who
the morning oh you love Zelda but the
more recent ones are losing the anks
they once had in the past now wait a
second you had my curiosity now you have
my attention what do you mean how do we
dodge how would you a quick dodge what
country would you like to see come to a
series of shows in the future that's a
great question
I would love to see what I love to see
I'd love to see Africa I'd love to see
India Russia would be great Italy Italy
with Jordan would be great I would love
to see yeah I love Ireland would be
great
something uh it's real on good to bet
somewhere weird in America would be
great
[Music]
no one literally no one knows yeah we
don't know yet they basically tell me
like the day before we go that's
honestly not really that much of an
exaggeration is it Ruby great
hey little B okay
I don't know I love England but it's
like I'd love to see like Vietnam or
Cambodia would be great I can just pick
up things that are on fire all right
XCOM give it to you go and give it to
your ex go and give it to you
ah my axe broke I got now branch
critical hit baby whoa
so that people were super nice in Mexico
they were really great and really
they're the star of our Mexico show is
the Mexican people which is what we
wanted Thanks going to use whoo but what
if the other Zelda games are dreams and
this is the one true game or link almost
died and sell the Henry directed that's
a good that's a good theory there's
actually a great theory about Super
Mario that that's the the actual thing
is like there it's all that Luigi abuse
we've talked about this luigi is
actually married to the princess and
Mario is just upset about it her or she
left Mario for Luigi and he gets upset
and so all those are just a fantasy all
those games are fantasy except for what
the first one it's great
[Music]
it's gonna give it to you give a deep
pick up weapons I have crabs it's all a
dream X there we go
there's a youtube cross-section for you
all right can't break these boxes
I did try what was I doing up here is
there a point to me being up there
nobody knows kind of push these big
things off the cliff which I can oh yeah
[Music]
you know what I might need this or
something right yeah we need this rain I
didn't hear a drop boom boom boom left
up that bone boom left I got a lot of
crap on me now look at this I'm like a
walking yard sale I'm like one of those
guys he's like a whole band you know
he's got the cymbals between his knees
and he's got like a bass drum and he
walks and then he plays a trombone and
then there's a penguin and you know the
whole thing I don't but the boom boom
boom peach is the antagonist Bowser in
the army are trying to reclaim their
land which is over on the fungal virus
have I played UFC Undisputed 3 I think I
played two what do we play the Conor
McGregor new played UFC yeah I have not
played three but UFC two is unbelievable
water running in this game a lot of
cardio so let's run around those
short-shorts here is making me question
my sexuality mm-hmm attracted to elves
are we nothing wrong with that
Oh ginormous just cuz I don't respond
doesn't mean I can't see the chat you
see all friend oh boy dead
hey I took that like a champ like dude
let's get out of here this way
you're welcome waffle farts or is it
waffle tarts it's waffle turrets it's
cuz I was watching Deadpool man X gon
give it to you going get Deadpool is
great I can't wait for Deadpool to do we
know who's playing cable yet
Nathan summers anybody
oh that was a great oral sex joke oral
meeting hearing it said elves have the
best oral sex get it because of their
pointy ears
I don't know that pointy ears would help
you second of hell other those actually
help you here I feel like you're gonna
want more I've never seen like a
satellite dish that's like pointy shape
I think I honestly think like having
pointy ears would actually hurt your
hearing I mean that cats I guess can
hear really well but that's more because
the owl scoop and also they can move
them independently they can move their
ears independently I'm not sure elves
can do that you know I'm saying yeah
inherently the shape of an L fear is not
is not helping collect the sound like a
like ours just point that out there yes
I heard Pierce Brosnan might be cable
also because there's a great picture of
them of ham who has it Pierce Brosnan
Brian Reynolds and somebody else all
together it's magic elves don't have to
explain it you're right I was gonna give
it to you go and give it to you Ron
Perlman better be careful Ron Perlman
and make a great cable I do feel like
Pierce Brosnan might be like a little
thin yeah lean to be cable you want
cables like a giant hulking massive of
warrior the giant crazy arm
David Harbor who's David Harbor well
it's getting dark guys
ah peace loves all I think that Conan
would like this game actually he's kind
of he digs these getting these kinds of
games I didn't get the parachute thing
yet Pamela we have to beat all the
shrines first multi dirts still trying
not even close wall to you multi that
you got you got a you got it up here in
sulky got a long ways to go
Oh in the face ah I have here already
got a couple branches that's not gonna
help me out of clubs
it's just club medicine
[Music]
don't figure how to dodge it sorry equip
that seems like it sucks yeah let's hit
it with this tree branch great idea oh
love do the face alright we're almost
out of time before we go I want to play
a quick other game just to show you guys
what the switches like if you haven't
seen it it's really great I'll play with
Beth we hold on what let's see here
showing you no idea paper Clippers what
is it called clipper glass and therefore
clip what is it called clip we're gonna
play this game here we go ready it's got
to be great
we're taking them out look at this
alright you take this wait stare eclipse
yes number Clippers Melissa McCarthy for
cable
let's McCarthy would be dope in an
excellent movie
this games adorable cheese in love with
it these little these little controllers
are adorable yeah cut it out together
all right we got to work together yeah
yeah yeah red clover blue pill which
ones do we do oh my god these have all
been opened up bowling for baskets what
do you want to do you think it's gone
give it to you Oh Scott nuts and I feel
you snips gon give it to you okay that's
right there little top buttons here
[Music]
right okay good
oh I see and but now this time this
shape here do you want to cut me into a
cubby best cut me cut me into a ramp I
guess yeah use it like you can scoop
like this you can make me into x-man
Maxie yeah and then I'll make you the
same as this but then it's easy because
I'm you can like pick them up cut like
this and rotate easy huh look at how
easy it is I'll make you ask you all
right I'll get back here you do your
thing yeah oh whoops
oh you release it every time you do this
whoops oh yeah thanks I'm carry it no I
give it to you damn it damn it
ex go and give it to you are you
reformed taught me cut me copy bet
that's good yeah all right here we go
scoop up this [ __ ]
[Music]
that's bad right I want to go up dammit
it's cute yeses Cupid fury all right
here we go I got it I got it here we go
[Music]
the momentum is what's killing me
get it take it you got it you got it
I'm gonna just stand on you not give me
the ball watch wait maybe we could get
maybe we could scoop it up yeah this is
it Tara this is awful
no I'm in the basket I'm actually stuck
in this basket people are screaming at
us right now
screaming at their things here we go
about this what happened who you played
it before it's kind of hard there we go
all right here we go
let's just make a V together here we go
ready all right cut me come here you got
it
okay all right here it comes
all right you step on me by accident
every time you're like okay that was
good all right guys it's been a Nintendo
switch it was super fun thank you for
joining us it was awesome yeah I mean I
love the switch I think it's great I'm a
big fan it's awesome we didn't even pull
it off the dock and play it portably but
if you can get one pick it up because
it's it's it's really really fun and I
love the couch co-op man bring it back
please couch co-op it's just fun to play
the friend I thank you guys for joining
us
twitch you guys are great youtube you
guys are interesting as always we'll see
you next Monday at noon watch the show
tonight Jesse Tyler Ferguson and and and
Nassim yeah the good and answer cane sir
cane sin cane sin cane is on the show
tonight that's right watch TBS 11
o'clock we'll see you guys next week in
there
you